on va passer au thème de ce club on va
parler du fond Marianne puisque hier à
l'arrivait beaucoup de remise de rapport
au Sénat on en a parlé en remise du
rapport la pénurie médicament de Tik Tok
et on va parler du très attendu rapport
de la commission d'enquête sur le fond
Marianne puisqu'il a été aussi rendu
hier absolument Claude rénale et
Jean-François Husson ont présenté un
rapport accablant n'hésitant pas à
utiliser le terme fiasco pour ce fond
Marianne la Commission a déplorer
l'urgence qui a prévalu sur tout autre
considération dans la mise en place de
cet appel à projet alors si dans un
premier temps un rapport de l'Inspection
générale de l'administration soulignait
un effacement de Marlène Schiappa de
l'appel à projet les sénateurs ont une
toute autre version selon eux il
apparaît très clairement que le cabinet
de la ministre et la ministre ont
outrepassé leur rôle en appuyant d'abord
la candidature de l'uspm de Mohamed
cifaoui en amont du comité de sélection
ainsi qu'en revenant sur l'octroi d'une
subvention de 100.000 euros à
l'association SOS Racisme alors même
qu'une décision favorable du comité de
sélection était intervenue ça c'est pour
l'amour du encore une fois on avale
c'est le contrôle des actions menées
avec l'argent public qui pêche pour des
sénateurs qui soulignent un manque
d'intérêt du pouvoir politique dès après
la sélection des projets le binôme rénal
Husson point donc là la responsabilité
politique de la ministre Marlène
Schiappa est-ce que des poursuites
judiciaires sont à suivre c'est le gros
dossier c'est les propos contradictoires
entre les personnes auditionnées et le
risque de faux témoignages qui
rappelons-le devant une commission
d'enquête aussi appelée par jour vont
passibles de 5 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 75000 euros d'amende mais comme
l'explique le président Claude rénal
c'est dans ce cas très précis
juridiquement difficile à établir
alors lorsque vous avez par exemple
deux témoignages uniquement l'homme qui
dit une chose et un autre témoignage qui
dit autre chose bah c'est pas de nature
à faire marquer un parjure parce que
lequel des deux est concerné finalement
bon donc c'est pour établir les choses
de manière juridique il faut en réalité
avoir un faisceau d'indices beaucoup
plus large avec des positions beaucoup
plus nombreuses qui permettent à ce
moment-là de dire de dire les choses
cette façon là à noter que Claude Raynal
a saisi le parquet national financier
d'un complément d'information qui
viendront donc se verser dans
l'information judiciaire ouverte il y a
quelques semaines par le PNF pour des
soupçons de détournement de fonds
publics par négligence abus de confiance
et prise légal d'intérêt fait des
recommandations 12 au total pour la
refonte des conditions d'attribution des
subventions aux associations elle se
divise en deux catégories les générales
d'abord la Commission propose ainsi de
définir un délai de droit commun de deux
mois pour les réponses aux appels à
projets nationaux autre proposition les
associations n'ayant pas un premier
bilan annuel d'activité donc au moins un
an d'existence ne pourront pas recevoir
de subventions de plus de 23000 euros le
deuxième volet ce sont les
recommandations propres au
fonctionnement du secrétariat général du
comité interministériel de prévention de
la délinquance et de la radicalisation
le cipdr la commission appelle à une
réflexion structurelle sur sa politique
de subvention de contre discours
républicains en ligne mais aussi
d'ouvrir son comité qui décide de
subventions à des personnalité
extérieure enfin les sénateurs
recommandent d'interdire toute
interférence du cabinet du ministre dans
l'instruction des dossiers et le cas
échéant de retracer de manière écrite et
motivée et dites interventions merci
Mathias merci pour ce résumé très
complet du rapport de cette commission
d'enquête sur le fond Marianne alors
Jean-François sévère un manque de
rigueur opacité des involtures qui ont
conduit au fiasco Benjamin
j'agis en prof mais là c'est typiquement
un cas pratique qu'on pourrait donner en
première année en sciences
administrative en demandant des
étudiants de trouver les 7 erreurs parce
qu'en réalité elles sont tellement
grosses que a priori même d'ailleurs
sans avoir subi le cours vous pouvez les
voir et vous pouvez voir les manquements
à la déontologie et les problèmes qui en
effet sont présents ici vous ne revenez
pas sur une subvention qui était
attribuée etc sont des choses qui
apparaissent relativement évidentes
alors après la vraie question c'est d'où
vient le dysfonctionnement est-ce que
vraiment il y a un amateurisme aussi
grand aussi fort au sein du gouvernement
et des cabinets ministériels pour que ce
type de choses puisse arriver est-ce
qu'ensuite il y a une volonté de
favoriser etc ça c'est le PNF qui va
trancher mais dans tous les cas en effet
là on a quelque chose qui mérite le
scandale qu'il a créé national financier
puisque effectivement il y a également
pardon une enquête judiciaire Arnaud
rapport accablant
mais ça dit quelque chose aussi sur le
fonctionnement du politique qui
privilégie la communication par rapport
à un événement qui vient de se dérouler
aussi dramatique soit-il plutôt que
l'action de fond et c'est bien ça le
sujet fondamental c'est que finalement
le a été créé à la suite de l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty comme une réponse de
communication à un événement qui avait
sidéré l'opinion publique donc déjà il
faut se poser la question sur j'avais
dit l'initiative racine en l'occurrence
était-elle utile avait-elle une portée
autant de questions que l'on ne s'est
pas posé parce que c'était tout
simplement encore un instrument de
visibilité
montrant la réactivité de la ministre
qui cherchait à expliquer à l'opinion
publique que elle elle avait pris en
compte une situation qui était une
situation absolument dramatique ça c'est
une c'est un sujet ensuite après il est
évident que les dysfonctionnements tels
qu'ils ont été pointés par la commission
sénatoriale sont tout à fait évidents y
a-t-il eu par exemple des indicateurs
d'évaluation des des initiatives qui ont
été
réalisé par le fond Marianne j'en doute
on a là si vous voulez l'exemple même de
la déresponsabilisation politique je
parle pas du pénal ça c'est la justice
qui dira en l'occurrence mais sur le
plan politique ça donne en effet
l'impression qu'on est face à une
gestion totalement amateur et désavoltes
comme on dit justement les sénateurs et
c'est le titre d'ailleurs du rapport
Arnaud puisque vous parliez de ce coup
politique dérive d'un coup politique
en effet le coût politique après
l'assistante Samuel Paty mais derrière
on s'interroge pas en réalité sur
l'effectivité et l'efficacité des
politiques publiques parce que en effet
évaluation un peu une affaire les biens
d'associations bon après tout c'est pas
si important au fond à quoi ça sert bah
ça a déjà servi ça a déjà servi parce
que le coût politique le coût de
communication a déjà eu lieu et
maintenant il faut gérer cet après et
cet après au fond et c'est peut-être ça
qui est dramatique c'est pas qu'on s'en
fiche mais presque c'est à dire que
l'efficacité de la dépense publique et
même l'efficacité de la politique
publique qui quand même normalement
devrait tenir chevillé au corps une
Marlène chappa qui faisait fronce sur la
laïcité et ben n'a pas tant d'importance
que ce soit dans la sélection ou dans
l'évaluation et bien on n'a pas cette
cette présence d'esprit et ça c'est un
vrai vrai problème et en effet ça dit
beaucoup sur la manière dont aujourd'hui
peuvent fonctionner si ce n'est nos
administrations en tout cas certaines
administrations vous avez le coup de com
mais ensuite la portée sur le réel c'est
secondaire et ça pose la question du
fonctionnement des administrations et de
la gestion ministérielle aussi Arnaud
l'interface entre le cabinet et
l'administration puisque manifestement
ce que met en avant le rapport c'est les
pressions du cabinet du politique sur
l'administration dans une procédure qui
doit d'abord obéir un certain nombre de
prérequis qui garantissent la neutralité
de la prise de décision là en la matière
on voit bien que il y a eu des
interventions qui sont des interventions
politiques alors c'est pas nouveau hein
c'est pas nouveau cette interventions
politiques sur les ADM mais là c'est
grossiste mais là le problème c'est que
c'est extrêmement grossier et que en
plus sur un sujet extrêmement sensible
on a le sentiment véritablement encore
une fois qu'on a fait de la
communication plus qu'une action de fond
et c'est ce qui d'ailleurs la plupart du
temps j'allais dire casse le lien de
confiance entre nos concitoyens et les
politiques c'était un énième exemple
d'une longue Italie j'allais dire de
l'épisode de ce type Benjamin sur cette
gestion ministérielle cette gestion
ministérielle elle en est fait
catastrophique c'est-à-dire que vous ne
donnez même pas l'apparence d'une forme
de neutralité que ce soit dans la
sélection dans la manière dont vous donc
là on arrive en effet ça s'est toujours
fait mais on arrive à une forme de
limite de skin faux pas faire et de ce
qui pose problème au regard même de
l'objectif du fond parce que faut quand
même revenir à l'origine on a une
initiative qui sur les principes est
bonne et je dirais dans ces modalités
théoriques n'est pas non plus mauvaise
et donc ce faisant là vous avez quelque
chose qui justement doit mettre en scène
et bien une action qui serait vertueuse
qui plus est dans une perspective qui
est une perspective et bien de
d'intervention de l'État qui serait une
intervention neutre et vous faites tout
le contraire donc on a un sujet qui
aujourd'hui devient sujet très
pragmatique parce que si demain on veut
relancer ces initiatives là quel
crédibilité quelle visibilité et pour
lequel suivi derrière malheureusement je
crains que cette initiative aujourd'hui
soit parte avec un vrai handicap et ça
sincèrement bah c'est dommage mais
est-ce que du coup ça pose la question
est-ce que le gouvernement peut mettre
la poussière sur le tapis peut ne tirer
aucune conclusion politique de douceur
c'est la question c'est la question
fondamentale encore une fois on l'a déjà
dit je crois sur ce plateau dans tout
autre pays démocratiques je ne suis pas
sûr que une ministre avait que un tel
résultat de son action publique en tout
cas concernant ce dossier soit en mesure
de rester dans un gouvernement et sauf
qu'en France c'est possible c'est
possible c'est possible pour le moment
en tout cas moi je suis assez frappé que
de toute façon
globalement Emmanuel Macron et quelqu'un
qui lâche très rarement ses amis
politiques il l'a fait au début en début
en début de premier mandat avec
notamment les ministres modem qui avait
été obligés de démissionner
au bout d'un bout d'un mois lors du
second du second du second gouvernement
Édouard Philippe mais finalement depuis
moi ce que je vois c'est plutôt un
soutien implicite au ministre qui sont
en difficulté sur le plan soit
judiciaire soit sur le plan médiatique
en France où on est pas pour enfin moi
je me souviens d'une époque même déjà
sous François Mitterrand savait commencé
alors un peu moins mais il y avait la
fameuse qu'on a pris entre guillemets la
fameuse jurisprudence Bérégovoy Balladur
ou des ministres mis en cause des
missionné on l'a vu sous François
Hollande un certain nombre de ministres
démissionnés on a vu tout de même sous
Nicolas Sarkozy des ministres qui
étaient seulement
l'objet de campagne médiatique les
mettez en cause être obligé de
démissionner là quand même force de
constater qu'on n'est plus du tout dans
ce paradigme-là et c'est un point
extrêmement important parce que en effet
cette jurisprudence très discutable et
rigobab à la dure mais malgré tout elle
donnait des jauges et elle permettait
d'avoir une forme d'idée du politique
lorsque Emmanuel Macron décide de
démissionner François Bayrou qui n'est
pas encore mis en examen lorsqu'il
décide de garder
Eric Dupond-Moretti qui lui est mis en
examen il fait sauter cette jauge là et
donc aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui fait que
vous tenez ou vous ne tenez pas comme
ministre et ben c'est l'acharnement que
mettra Mediapart à vous faire
démissionner d'un côté et de l'autre
côté la capacité Corée manuel Macron et
la volonté qu'aurait Emmanuel Macron de
vous soutenir mordicus et ça
fondamentalement ça crée quelque chose
de très très malsain et donc cette
jurisprudence berger qui était très
imparfaite au moins elle permettait
d'avoir une visibilité aujourd'hui en
effet tout dépend du fait du prince
est-ce que ça affaibli la démocratie du
cours non oui parce que cette
jurisprudence était certes parfois
injuste mais elle avait quand même le
mérite
de montrer qu'il y avait un devoir
d'exemplarité alors qui était plus ou
moins respecté en l'occurrence au cas
par cas parfois mais quand même là
aujourd'hui en effet on a le sentiment
que selon que vous êtes 800 ou selon que
vous êtes faible vous n'avez pas le même
traitement en l'occurrence et ça en
effet ça a affaiblit la démocratie
forcément et de la démocratie on
affaiblissement de la démocratie parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous prenez les
enquêtes ça devient quasiment une
banalité de le dire vous avez une un
manque de confiance dans la politique ça
veut pas dire que la classe politique
est corrompue je crois qu'on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a la classe politique
la plus propre de notre histoire parce
que si vous voulez être corrompu
aujourd'hui entre les différents acteurs
à la fois les médias et de l'autre côté
les différentes autorités HTV etc vous
avez beaucoup de mal à vous en tirer et
objectivement on fait démissionné en
condamne des gens aujourd'hui pour des
choses qui
historiquement
apparaissent relativement peanuts par
rapport à ce qui est pu être produit
jadis les valises de biais qui
circulaient dans des années 80 ou dans
le 70 c'était d'un autre niveau mais
néanmoins le fait que justement il y ait
pas de jauge le fait qu'il y ait une
sorte de gloubi-boulga fait que et bien
la multiplication des affaires donne le
sentiment à l'opinion qu'on a une classe
politique corrompue et donc c'est
beaucoup plus une mise en scène et je
dirais une régularité des règles qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on a des vrais
problèmes et ça le politique de vente
tirer les conséquences avec des
conséquences dans les urnes évidemment
avec une désaffection une perte de
crédibilité des politiques clairement
quand vous regardez toutes les études
d'opinion qui sont menées maintenant
depuis un certain nombre d'années je
pense notamment au baromètre du Cevipof
sur la confiance dans les institutions
et dans la confiance dans l'autorité
politique en particulier vous avez des
jugements très sévères qui sont émis par
les Français sur j'allais dire la vertu
entre guillemets des dirigeants à tort
ou à raison en tout cas c'est une
réalité vous avez par exemple une
question
ouverte ou les Français après de plus de
50% exprime du dégoût donc sans dit long
quand même sur l'appréciation qui est
portée sur une partie de la de la classe
politique donc je crois qu'en effet ça
c'est un vrai c'était un vrai sujet et
la désinfection dans les urnes elle
n'est pas liée je pense seulement à ce
type de question elle est liée aussi au
comment dire à l'appréciation d'un
manque d'efficacité dans l'action dans
l'action politique oui à trois choses en
réalité c'est à dire que voter pour quoi
en réalité bah vous votez pour déjà un
personnel politique qui a des
convictions prenons quelqu'un qui a
siéger ici Charles Pasqua qui n'était
peut-être pas sur tous les aspects un
ange mais dont on peut estimer que il
avait une colonne vertébrale idéologique
et donc des moments où vous votez
quelqu'un pour quelqu'un qui a une
colonne vertébrale idéologique vous
votez d'abord pour une idéologie cette
idéologie les structurée et se faisant
et bien la morale et je dirais presque
secondaire ensuite vous votez pour
l'efficacité politique dans les années
80-90 le politique dit attendez
l'idéologie c'est vieux c'est vieillot
mais nous faisons le pari de
l'efficacité ce pari de l'efficacité
voyez où est aujourd'hui la France il
est pas vraiment gagné on peut au moins
s'accorder là-dessus donc l'idéologie la
structure idéologique
l'honnêteté idéologique n'est plus là
l'efficacité non plus reste la morale
lorsque la morale même de façon
subreptise encore une fois on n'a pas
une classe politique corrompue mais
n'est plus là non plus pourquoi
voulez-vous croire aux politiques alors
ça affaiblit la démocratie on le
rappelle que ce fond Chapa il a il se
font Marianne pardon il a été créé par
Marlène Schiappa après l'assassinat de
Samuel Patti est-ce que cette affaire
elle affaiblit aussi elle abîme aussi
les valeurs de la République
j'irai pas jusque là
est-ce qu'elle affaiblit les valeurs de
la République dans le combat contre
l'islamisme je ne pense pas parce que
globalement quand on regarde là aussi
quand même les évolutions de l'opinion
publique on a une opinion publique qui
est en demande de fermeté et en demande
d'autorité nonobstant les
dysfonctionnements liées au fond
Marianne et d'ailleurs je ne suis pas
sûr que si vous voulez
ce qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui ce
matin autour de cette table aille
beaucoup plus loin elle a un que les
cercles dirigeants avec les cercles
médiatiques j'ai pas l'impression que
dans l'opinion publique aujourd'hui la
question du fond Marianne soit un sujet
essentiel quand bien même en effet ce
qui est reproché à Marin tient pas me
paraît assez fondé en tout cas sur le
point de vue du fonctionnement dans le
rapport de sénatorial donc ça je ne
pense pas que ça ça affaiblisse
véritablement le combat de la République
contre ses ennemis et ses adversaires
par contre en effet c'est ce qu'on a dit
ça affaiblit considérablement la
crédibilité de l'action ministériel ça
affaiblit considérablement si vous
voulez la confiance que les les Français
peuvent avoir dans leur ministre et dans
et dans leur représentance c'est ça le
problème c'est qu'on a quand même une
lent une longue corrosion de ce lien de
confiance qui s'est installé depuis des
années et des années des années et qui
ne cesse de s'accroître et qui en effet
s'explique aujourd'hui enfin qui qui
dont les résultats sont notamment la une
participation électorale qui diminue des
votes contestataires etc etc oui ça
fragilise une coordination d'acteurs
parce que l'objectif du fond Marianne
c'est également d'avoir un état qui soit
une force d'impulsion pour avoir une
réponse en termes de discours en termes
d'idéologie aux attentes à la laïcité or
il faut un état crédible crédible au
regard des Français également mais
également on regarde des partenaires
potentiels au sein de la société civile
et ça c'est pas perdu mais ça va être
très compliqué à reconstruire parce que
évidemment ceux qui ont voulu postuler
qui ont cru en cette initiative et ben
pour les réembarquer aujourd'hui dans le
navire il va falloir y aller et ça fait
du pas la lutte contre l'islamisme non
je crois pas fondamentalement je ne
pense pas que ça affaibli alors que les
que les adversaires de la République se
saisissent du sujet pour décrédibiliser
la lutte contre l'islamisme j'allais
dire c'est presque de bons guerre entre
guillemets en la matière mais je ne
pense pas que c'est véritablement un
impact dans l'opinion publique moi je
suis quand même très frappé sur encore
une fois toutes les enquêtes qui sont
menées maintenant depuis un certain
nombre de temps sur malgré tout la
demande de fermeté et la demande
d'autorité que les Français expriment
sur cette question de la lutte contre
l'islamisme je crois qu'ils ont
parfaitement
identifié quelle était l'adversaire par
contre ils ont des doutes sur la
capacité du pouvoir politique et de
l'état être à la mesure des enjeux
auxquels nous sommes confrontés et ils
ont des doutes légitimes mais du pouvoir
politique ou de ce gouvernement et
d'Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui vous savez Emmanuel Macron
ça fait quand même maintenant six ans
qu'il est au pouvoir donc évidemment
celui qui est principalement
identifié comme le moteur principal de
l'action publique c'est le président de
la République alors évidemment il y a le
passé les gens en plus de mémoire qu'on
ne l'imagine quand même aussi malgré
tout mais c'est une mémoire un peu
diffuse elle existe et il voit que quand
même il y a une dégradation de la
situation depuis un certain nombre
d'années ça ils le constate oui souvent
quand vous êtes conscientiste on vous
demande qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour
réformer les institutions et en effet
des choses à faire je vais pas vous dire
le contraire sinon je cracherai dans ce
métier mais le vrai problème aujourd'hui
ce qui explique en partie qu'on ait une
crise démocratique de la Suède au
Portugal et de la Pologne aux États-Unis
c'est un problème de potence et d'un
potence publique et en la matière force
est de constater que est-ce que vraiment
le politique peut encore agir sur le
réel ça c'est pas évident et c'est pas
Macron c'est pas etc et donc comment
est-ce qu'on arrive à reconstruire une
vision politique qui permet justement de
se ressaisir du réel cette cela vient un
peu plus affaiblir cette crédibilité
parce qu'il pouvait y avoir
éventuellement à Paris sur la question
de la laïcité là je suis à la fois
autant optimiste en même temps plus
pessimiste Carnot il n'y a pas de vrais
clivage politique un peu malgré tout
mais regardez les Torah elvé ou même
lectorat la fi on a des électorats qui
sont plutôt attachés à la laïcité de
manière majeure et parfois même de
manière assez dure quand on pense
notamment à électorat ELV ce qui est
très paradoxal au vu des positions du
parti en revanche il y a un vrai
question je il y a une vraie question
jeunesse on a aujourd'hui dans la
jeunesse chez les moins de 25 ans et
notamment chez les moins de 18 ans une
vraie remise en cause de ses valeurs et
c'est là que ce type de fond peut avoir
vraiment un impact parce que il faut
pouvoir s'adresser à cette jeunesse et
ça les pouvoirs publics excatera ne le
peuvent pas réellement faut trouver des
acteurs de terrain pour trouver des
soutiens et ça ça implique bah ce type
de choses
moi je suis de toute façon j'ai toujours
été réservé sur l'initiative du fond
Marianne je pense que ce n'est pas
l'outil absolument essentiel pour lutter
contre toutes les formes de séparatisme
de sécessionnisme et j'allais dire de
complaisance vis-à-vis du séparatisme et
du sécessionnisme le vrai sujet c'est
fondamentalement c'est que notre
République a abandonné depuis 40 ans un
modèle qui est le modèle de
l'assimilation au moment où nous avions
quand même des vagues de migration qui
était massives et où il fallait plus que
jamais en l'occurrence permettre à ce
moteur de l'assimilation de pouvoir
continuer à fonctionner quant à l'action
de l'État en France je pense que si vous
voulez gagner une différence sur les
questions d'efficacité pour rebondir sur
ce que disait Benjamin pourquoi la crise
du politique est plus forte en France
vraisemblablement qu'ailleurs c'est que
nous avons un rapport à l'État qui est
historiquement constitué d'une manière
différente de celle d'un certain nombre
d'autres démocraties merci Arnaud et
Benjamin pour ce débats vous restez avec
nous on va partir sur la route du Tour
les coureurs sont dans les Pyrénées hier
ils ont grimpé le mythique col du
Tourmalet Jonathan du prix Azay nous
emmène sur les pentes de ce g en
Pyrénées une légende du cyclisme
c'est un colosse pyrénéen qui ne
s'escalade pas à la légère le Tourmalet
monument du cyclisme aimantent les
amateurs du monde entier sur ses pentes
s'attaquer à ce géant ses exposer à 17
km de montée sans répit à 7% de pente
moyenne et 1400 mètres de dénivelé
positif sans compter l'allera climatique
ce jour-là 14 degrés et une brume à
couper au couteau un plaisir autant
qu'une souffrance en moyenne les
amateurs mettent une heure 40 pour
atteindre son sommet à 2115 mètres
d'altitude mais pour beaucoup comme Yvan
le principal c'est déjà d'envenir à bout
de 5 km facile mais après
faut grimper 9% 10% incontournable en
haut du col la photo devant la statue
d'Octave lapiz premier cycliste à être
venu à bout du géant sans descendre de
vélo c'était en 1910 sur le Tour de
France tout un symbole pour Dave venu du
pays de Galles cette montée il ne
l'oubliera jamais
de voir accompli quelque chose
sur le bord de cette petite route
française c'est juste incroyable je
pense que ça n'existe nulle part
ailleurs dans le monde si le tour
malaise est toujours autant tourner les
têtes c'est qu'il est intimement lié à
l'histoire de la Grande Boucle à ce jour
il est le col le plus franchi par la
course on vous accueille donc dans la
maison du Tourmalet nouvellement
construite en s'appuyant sur des images
d'archives les murs de ce lieu retracent
la folle épopée de ce col qui regorge
d'anecdotes
les organisateurs du premier passage du
Tour de France au col du Tourmalet ce
sont fait traiter d'assassin par les
journalistes parce qu'on peut s'imaginer
ce que c'était en 1910 de monter à vélo
au col du Tourmalet et c'est pas
vraiment les intempéries
ou même les difficultés techniques mais
c'était plutôt la peur de la montagne
l'exposition interactive est aussi la
part belle à l'époque contemporaine en
scannant ce cliché danseleck et Alberto
Contador on peut revivre en vidéo ce
mémorable manoamano de 2010 remporté par
le Luxembourgeois l'objectif en fait
c'est plutôt d'accueillir l'ensemble des
visiteurs du col du temps Mali leur
offrir un espace où ils peuvent se
renseigner sur ce que sur ce qui s'est
passé et revivre voilà cette aventure
cyclotoïstique donc c'est un espace qui
est entièrement gratuit à disposition de
l'ensemble des visiteurs du col du
Tourmalet
en fond de vallée aussi le Tourmalet
irradie sur tout le territoire à
bannière de Bigorre Octave Vito rythme
du col c'est un café vélo assorti d'une
boutique et d'un atelier le lieu
souhaite surfer sur l'exposition
extraordinaire offerte par le géant
pyrénéen mais aussi sur l'un de ses
fondateurs le cycliste professionnel
Bruno armirail
autant de cyclistes et autant de
personnes qui viendraient donc voilà le
but c'est vraiment de tous les gens qui
qui passent par le Tourmalet qui
s'arrête ici ça serait ça serait super
il y a des petits souvenirs aussi à
apprendre des petits maillots au cours
du Tourmalet chez Octave voilà des
bidons le col du Tourmalet presque une
capitale du vélo à lui tout seul a vu
défiler tous les plus grands grimpeurs
de l'histoire du cyclisme Fausto copie
bas à montes et dix Merckx ou encore
plus récemment le français Thibaut Pinot
cette belle image de la route du Tour
Mathias on regarde ce qu'elle a une de
nos quotidien
[Musique]
et Mathias c'est pas encore les vacances
pour nous mais c'est les vacances pour
certains c'est Halloween de la presse
régionale mais pour des centaines de
milliers de Français c'est bien le coup
d'envoi des vacances d'où cette question
de la Voix du Nord près pour le grand
départ
ose des péages prix du carburant
information trafic il faut avoir toutes
ces informations en main car comme le
dit le journal basé à Lille un voyageur
nordiste en vaut 2 informations qui va
donc de père aussi avec cette une de
l'union de Reims les anges gardiens de
vos vacances une piqûre de rappel a bien
fait attention aux patrouilleurs des
sociétés d'autoroutes qui sont là on ne
le rappellera jamais assez pour notre
sécurité donc attention à eux et ces
vacanciers vont sûrement dans des lieux
touristiques on est dans des lieux
bondés où il est difficile d'être seul
on parle de plus en plus de sur tourisme
Midi Libre s'interroge sur une possible
saturation de ces sites touristiques le
journal Montpellier Reims s'est rendu à
Saint-Guilhem le désert dans l'Hérault
petit joyau médiéval qui a mis en place
une série de mesures pour faire face à
l'afflux massif de monde informé que le
parking est complet interdire totalement
l'accès à certains sites pour les
protéger ou fermer les terrasses à 22
les pistes sont nombreuses pour éviter
que ça surchauffe et du coup ça porte
mal son nom ce vendredi c'est aussi le
coup d'envoi des rencontres d'Aix à la
française voilà comment certains
présentent les rencontres économiques
qui s'installeront pendant trois jours
dans la cité du roi René et qui feront
d'ex comme le dit la Provence le centre
du monde économique la présidente de la
Banque centrale européenne Christine
Lagarde et le ministre de l'Économie
Bruno Le Maire auront les premiers rôles
de cette 23e édition faramineux 67
sessions débats 360 intervenants et plus
de 6000 visiteurs attendus avec
l'objectif de recréer de l'espoir dans
le tissu économique on parlait tout à
l'heure des vacances d'autres pensent
déjà à rentrer et oui car la rentrée
scolaire se prépare déjà Oriane surtout
du côté du professorat les Dernières
Nouvelles d'Alsace alertes école
cherchent aux professeur il ne manque
que désespérément dans le titre si le
journal alsacien souligne que les
résultats au concours de recrutement des
enseignants s'améliorent plus de 3000
postes restent à pourvoir à la rentrée
avec forcément des conséquences comme en
une du Journal de Saône-et-Loire qui
dans son édition chalonnaise que les
fermetures de classe vont se poursuivre
et que cela crée on peut le comprendre
de l'exaspération on finit avec une
nouveauté Mathias allez regardez cette
une de Corse-Matin journal que vous
connaissez bien Oriane
a changé c'est sa formule Corse-Matin
propose à partir d'aujourd'hui une
nouvelle formulation électorale nouveau
logo nouvelle maquette des articles plus
courts et plus denses mais aussi et ce
n'est pas une petite info un nouveau
slogan fini au Jay in Corsica Odie c'est
ça et place à Corsica infanti ça veut
dire quoi
ce matin on verra cette nouvelle formule
du journal merci Mathias merci beaucoup
pour cette revue de presse merci
Benjamin Morel merci Arnaud qui va tout
de suite aller lire la nouvelle formule
de course ce matin
on regarde la formule de la revue
Politique
non c'est pas concerté avec Corse
politique des liaisons tumultueuses la
nouvelle formule de la revue politique
et parlementaire merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis pour voir revoir cette émission
c'est sur notre plateforme public
sena.fr on se retrouve lundi très bon
weekend
[Musique]